[Applause]
another fight uh
this weekend that was amazing we watched
in the green room was uh the canelo
fight against uh i heard about this
and canelo um
canelo needs these fights man because he
is the best right now
he could go down as one of the best ever
but if he doesn't have strong opponents
there's no interest yeah this was a
strong opponent so we watched
right yeah these past people he was
fighting these bums we didn't give a
[ __ ] about this was a strong opponent we
watched
it is in canelo's promotional company's
best interest to start
building up the fighters he's about to
fight yeah because if not we're not
going to watch him we're not going to
witness the greatness
we watch this time and we win this
[ __ ] greatness yeah i mean that man
is nice with it bro
yeah and if i'm the zone or whoever the
[ __ ] is promoting him officially
all i'm doing is dumping money into
every other contender
making them look like beasts making them
look amazing convincing the public
that they're a worthy opponent the same
way the ufc did that [ __ ] with khabib
everybody could be fought the ufc
convinced us this is going to be the one
justin gaichy this is going to be the
one that's empowering this is going to
be the one
conor this is going to be the one they
knew damn well none of them was going to
do [ __ ]
right so you need to do the same thing
with canelo so you could build up his
legend
that is the beauty of having one
promotional company have all the
fighters
you get to build up all these other
[ __ ] so your star yeah
looks dominant yeah build it up man
because that guy's special and
unfortunately
if you're not mexican you don't give a
[ __ ] yeah i don't the mexicans do
70 000 of them inside dallas stadium i
watched the triple g
fight maybe the first or second one they
had three right two
two yeah the first one a lot of people
thought he lost
yeah and the second one i think more
people thought canelo won okay
and then i think the first one was even
a draw it was a draw yeah but a lot of
people thought he lost a lot of thought
triple g got host second one he won
correct yeah so he's lost to floyd only
that's his only loss
uh yeah and then he has two draws okay
yeah but yeah that's
that's a [ __ ] good record you could
go down to tons of fights the guy's been
fighting
his [ __ ] teenager like it's it's
unbelievable but he just keeps getting
better and better man like if you really
want to really want to see greatness
that guy is
truly great at what he does he's
fighting overweight like he shouldn't be
this
at 168 the guy should be fighting at 154
or 160
maybe he should not be fighting at 168
against these much bigger guys
and he overpowers them he can't be hit
but it's it's truly impressive what he's
doing yeah
yeah man is he gonna get any of those
like legacy fights you think like
pacquiao or any of that well i don't
think that that's interesting anymore
because those guys are so old
and unfortunately the state of boxing is
is very hard to build up star power
right now
nobody's really interested none of these
boxers have uh
engaging enough personalities via social
media they might be engaging but they
don't know how to get that [ __ ] across
social media
so we can't create those big money
fights
it's it's a real [ __ ] shame man
because you won't notice how great he is
unless he has great
people to fight against yeah you're only
as good as your opponents
yeah you know it's let me ask you a
question i remember when him and floyd
fought sergio
cohen said something to me like floyd is
very smart and that's why he's fighting
canelo now
because he knows canelo is going to get
better i hate this i hate this argument
because it discredits floyd it's like
floyd either fought them too early or
fought them too late or fought it's like
nah so that's
better to that end is floyd floyd then
still better than canelo now
you think is that something you can
answer it's tricky because canelo was
fighting at 168 pounds and floyd
only fought the highest he ever felt was
154 he should have never even fought it
that week
yeah so it's like i
i don't think anybody could touch floyd
and i think floyd would have solved
whatever puzzle
yeah and maybe that's against canelo but
yeah i don't think he could canelo
believes that he would knock him out
they've asked canelo he's like yeah if i
was in my prime half off floyd then i'm
knocking him out
you're not knocking him out nobody could
knock him out and the same thing is
likely gonna happen maybe he lands a few
less punches but it's going to be hard
to hit you but it's going to be even
harder to hit him
yeah i remember watching that fl at that
fight and being yeah
this is [ __ ] floating i was there
live brother yeah they put on a
show it was incredible i mean it was
easy it was light work no i mean people
were shocked how light work it was but i
hate that
argument to discredit floyd they always
say like he fought people too late or
too early
and it's just like no bro he fights them
when they're valuable enough
right you know if the big money fight is
there that's when he fights them yeah
you know
it's but everybody wants to try to
discredit the king